the prehistoric stone circle came into
view when a dam in the spanish province
of casarus dropped to a quarter of its
usual capacity the stones were first
discovered in 1926
and have only been fully visible four
times since
the discovery is an unexpected side
effect of the worst drought in europe in
decades
in serbia the river danube is at its
lowest level in nearly a century
revealing the wreckages of 20 german
warships which were sunk during world
war ii
this is what remains from the war
between the army of the soviet union and
the german war flotilla there's about 10
000 kilograms of explosive devices here
we're not sure if they can explode but
you can imagine the problems if they do
in germany the drought has exposed
so-called hunger stones at sections of
the river rhine
centuries ago they were placed on dry
riverbeds to warn future generations
their exposure could signal famine
away from europe and a drought in china
has revealed ancient statues of buddha
on an island that's usually submerged
the statues are believed to be 600 years
old
i read in the newspaper the statues are
from the ming and king dynasties it's
rare to see weather like this i'm
worried i think it's a warning to us
rainfall in the yangtze basin has been
around 45 lower since july authorities
say as many as 66 rivers across
southwest china have dried up this
summer
with many scientists saying hotter days
as a result of global warming are here
to stay
more relics from the past are sure to
emerge victoria gatenbee al jazeera